i'm like
let's serve up some news sunny side up
you have to check this out it's the
first fabulous image from house of gucci
it's adam driver and lady gaga
and they're filming in italy right now
with director ridley scott
and you have to see these behind the
scenes images they're playing maurizio
gucci
head of gucci and his wife patricia
so i don't know if you remember ross but
maurizio was murdered in 1995
and the hit was ordered by patricia
his then ex-wife and he left her for a
younger woman in 1991 and then patricia
served
18 years in prison and the film explores
all that and comes out this november
and you guys all smell that do you know
what that is oscars
they're going to win oscars for this
apartment therapy reports that the pizza
roulette
cut and surfboard is here to help check
this
out it turns clean up into a little game
you serve your pizza on here and as each
person takes a slice guess what they
reveal what their
post-pizza chore is and just like that
the pizza board has spoken i love this
so much because whenever i'm eating all
i'm thinking about is like oh i got to
do the dishes i got to do that now it's
like
you get assigned a chore i would like
one of these slices to say ross you must
walk around the block eight times
stop eating pizza put it down all right
i'm gonna take a piece of pizza
and then mine says have another slurpee
oh man you won the pizza slice lottery
can i just take a slice to see what my
chore would be
yup she doesn't like that oh my
oh
usa today reports that beer is getting
better for you
kind of more and more breweries are
adding electrolytes to their broods
so you're going to start seeing new
beers infused with chia seeds
bee pollen minerals b vitamins and
mediterranean sea salt
and i mean you could rock one of these
after a long hike
i mean i what are they not i i this
is just ridiculous yeah yeah i know
they're trying to find an excuse to
drink more beer and i'm not buying it
i don't like beer because it to me it
tastes like pennies it's not for me
oh yeah i know what you mean but if
someone told me that like a pinot grigio
is something i could grab after the gym
then i you know
bench squatted dumbbell i don't know i
don't know about working out but
sounds like a motivator i actually love
beer and i love the taste of it
so for real i love it i can't even
imagine going to like a ball game
or anything and i even drink
non-alcoholic beer sometimes
it too is like a healthy beer from the
man
and the group of people who took the
form as far as it could be taken
i can't love the john oliver show more
but keep your eyes on us guys because
we're coming for you
last week tonight shoots here at the cbs
broadcast center where we shoot our show
we've already staked our claim over your
domain in the building
that used to be your entrance before you
gave it up
are you coming back to the building
let's do that
i love the john levi's show i was
watching it when that happened i
screamed out loud in my living room
the fact that john oliver and his
amazing
team knows we exist rossi i can't be
more excited i mean
they really did advance the forum oh my
gosh they've changed the game completely
and
they're watching hi i'm mike
you know drew you said historic and
there are so many firsts
in all these different categories let's
start with best picture and
i think this is going to be a great race
let's start with judas and the black
messiah
is nominated the first all-black
producing team to be nominated for best
picture
this film is fabulous there's also
menari got a nod
making producer christina oh the first
asian american woman to be nominated and
how about making streamer history
netflix has two best picture nominations
with mank and the trial of chicago seven
they are the first
streamer to do that plus they have a
whopping and it's kind of crazy 35 nods
overall that's more than
any other studio congrats to them and i
think it's also really cool that you can
watch
six of the eight best picture nominees
online right this second
so you're up to speed judas and the
black messiah and the father are the
only ones that are in theaters yeah that
is very neat because a lot of times when
the oscar nominations come out people
are like
i've never even heard of that what is
that i know you can watch him at home
right now
yeah it is amazing
[Applause]
and today i picked the gold standard of
backpacks i've never found one
better it's the jansport this is my
personal one actually this is yours for
reals
oh yeah cute drew listen um
i am not a bad girl ross it's all about
that they evenly distributed why do i
kind of look like a
weird like a hiker in like the swiss
alps
yeah a little bit um all i know
is that when nancy javonan fallon and i
used to start flower
films we would walk into meetings in big
hollywood board rooms and we would be
having these on our backs
and they carried all of our presentation
supplies
and i gotta tell you i've never grown
out of it the jansport really is my best
friend
and the bag that i have carried my whole
life so
i highly recommend if you're going back
to school
back to life you're an adult you're a
kid it's the best way to carry your
stuff around and guess what
you're hands-free